ha sido bien interesante porque ayer en
una rueda de prensa que dio el
presidente selenski con los medios con
algunos de los más importantes medios
españoles fue Claro en afirmar que una
de las prioridades de Ucrania con la
presidencia de España era lograr una
comunicación y una mejor relación y
apoyo de esos países latinoamericanos
que como bien sabemos Aunque no es una
posición conjunta de toda América Latina
Pues sí hay países que se han mostrado
neutrales o no han rechazado totalmente
esta invasión ellos Sánchez dijo que
básicamente que él sabe que la posición
de rechazo de América Latina a la
soberanía está ahí pero que aprovecharán
esa Cumbre entre América Latina y Europa
que se realizará en los próximos días en
Bruselas Para volver a explicar a estos
países porque Europa está comprometida
en la ayuda a Ucrania y por qué es
hacerlo ayer en esa entrevista que daba
selensky dijo que él estaba dispuesto a
ir a América Latina a explicarle a la
ciudadanía de nuestro continente Por qué
era necesario apoyar a Ucrania Cuál era
la lucha que estaba librando Ucrania
pero si aseguró en su momento también
que ningún país hasta el momento le ha
dado esta invitación Pedro Sánchez no
quiso ser crítico con América Latina
pero aseguró que iba a a hacer todo lo
posible por realmente crear esos lazos
no solamente ya con el continente
americano con la parte sur del
continente americano sino también con lo
que se llama internacionalmente con ese
Sur global Así que es un papel de Europa
porque sigue insistiendo selenski que la
guerra no solamente se gana militarmente
que es importante la presión política y
que para eso necesitan que todos los
países apoyen a Ucrania presionen a
Rusia y así lograr el retiro de las
tropas y el fin de esta guerra